this is the story of how comedian Ryan
sickler almost died after going to the
doctor for a routine back surgery that
was only supposed to take three hours
shortly after his arrival the 9 A.M
procedure was delayed till 6 PM due to a
leak in the operating room the day after
his surgery there was an unusual
swelling around the incision and Ryan
was placed on bed rest even though the
doctors had originally recommended
plenty of daily movement and exercise to
help heal the wound eventually the
swelling got so bad and emergency
procedure had to be done and yet again
Ryan sickler was kept waiting for over
six hours past the scheduled time once
the second operation was complete a
physical therapist put Ryan through a
series of standing and climbing tests
before deeming him ready to go home but
as the doctors were telling Ryan he was
safe to leave he felt his lungs clodding
with blood and a sharp pain down the
left side of his body and there were
massive pulmonary emblems covering both
of his lungs what was supposed to be a
routine back surgery kept the comedian
in the hospital for weeks and he had to
use a cane for months but thankfully
Ryan survived to tell the tale and is
doing better now